[Music]
that plague October 27th that play
changed my life
the doctor said he broke the next time
you saw see today this was we dead on
that field
I always knew the dedication that I had
in myself and the motivation I had at
myself that one day I would get my
chance to be on the gridiron again if I
get the opportunity to get the chance to
play I'm gonna make it Delvin Breaux
corner back from the wall of Louisiana I
[Music]
love football I love about passion for
football since I was four years old love
the game I would do anything to play in
the game big injury massive injury not I
still want to play football just because
that's just the passion and love I have
for the game the type of player I was
was a physical investment corner I will
model my game after Darrelle Revis it's
like we played the same way physical I
was going to get in receiving face and
we gonna make the quarterback not throw
away fear in the eyes just let him know
that this guy's for real
[Applause]
this is a player who back in a high
school football game in 2006 had three
vertebrae seriously injured so bad that
a doctor told him he could have died on
the field
as I came down I made the hit the big
collision all I could just think about
was you know am I gonna live am I gonna
dodge right here on the 23 yard line and
there every time I come down here I get
one knee and I just take a prayer just
to thank God for you know giving me this
opportunity to get up and be able to
walk off the field and and it's just a
miracle the game was going great that
had scouts out there that LSU Scouts
came and they saw me before the game and
it was like we're gonna be up there
watching so I had to put on the show I
didn't care what I had to do to make a
play that game and we running down don't
kick off and I'm coming down the left
hand side of field and I was about the
20 yard line where I just made my plate
[Music]
I hit the guy right in his knee the next
thing I knew I was out I couldn't move
my body at all my teammates coming at me
bro let's go we need to get up I was
just like man I would but I can't get up
and then within 2 seconds man like a
bright light like just shining is
something I've never seen before
my coaches came over there was the smell
of salad inside yeah all right yeah I'm
good and I got up on my own power and I
actually walked off the field taking my
own helmet off and you know getting
ready to go back in because I didn't
think my neck was broken and then I felt
this sharp pain shoot up on the back of
my neck someone sat down on my dad and
him Kane gave me some ibuprofen and
eventually excruciating pains just came
up the back of my neck and I just told
my dad to go get the ambulance and take
me to the hospital
that's why I found out I broke my neck
the doctor came up to me was like man
you're supposed to be dead I don't
understand how you're alive right now as
soon as I saw his x-rays and cat scan of
the neck I was really surprised that he
was neurologically fine it was like a
miracle my expectations were really
thinking about football or any kind of a
context for in the future was out of the
question
thinking about him and much as he loved
the game and how mentally he's gonna
come from this that was the most hardest
part and I was like when are you that's
it you know I figured everything all he
worked for and everything I just thought
and ended right there
[Music]
LSU added my scholarship I talked with
Les Miles and the staff and they wanted
me there they gave me the opportunity to
get myself held up that didn't work out
because I didn't get cleared by three of
their doctors you know it kind of hit me
at one point was like man football
really might just be over with [ __ ]
and then I following my fiance Kasey
tight tone
she got me believing that I can actually
be back on top we were kind of like well
why don't we try out for some other
football teams and he got in on a
semi-pro team it's what he needed and it
definitely brought him back to life and
the first game I played in I made my
first tackle that moment how it jumped
up was like I'm not dead I'm actually
alive I actually made a tackle from
there he started doing with the Voodoo
tryout he played a couple of games
before he got noticed by the CFL made it
to CFL I had my teammates they always
kept saying you need to be NFL right not
bad it's too easy for you
they're well enough to get a visits by
14 other team I was actually working out
for the Tampa Bay Buccaneers my agent
just showed me the phone I'm like what
he's like what's this area code
they say 500 fully and I just I said no
the section that call when you have guys
like selling payton and mickey loomis
talk to me and you tell me that they
want me they they don't want me to lead
a facility until I sign up with him was
was just incredible
[Music]
every year since I've known him
basically he's had a goals board every
year it's always said he in a football
played football made me the person I am
today I always knew in my mind if I'm
alive if I'm able to run and walk and
think on my own then I knew I had the
capability the plan my dad kept telling
me say the only way you're gonna be back
at the top is if you outwork everybody
that always stick in the back of my head
till this day
it's unreal is like a dream and this
year some time had to pinch myself run
the Hennessy was real I played for
Goretti Saints growing up now I'm in
Orleans st. and it's gonna make my city
proud I made my family proud to know
that I can actually come back and do it
I love in a city on which I was raised
me I can't wait to go out there and play
for who that nation you're a local given
you feel antic pressure in the whole
city kind of knows your story and is
rooting for you know what bill pressure
you know it's what I do I play football
I love the game and I'm happy that I'm
here with this organization and uh we
trying to win a Super Bowl
you